salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
cet été vous serez sûrement très
nombreux et nombreux à vous prélasser
sur les plages et vous y serez très bien
accompagné sur le sable dans le sable et
dans l'eau une multitude de petits
animaux ont élu domicile et vanne de
Bretagne qui n'a pas peur de se mouiller
va nous les présenter
[Musique]
salut les amis mais tu ne crois pas
c'est bien dire je crois que j'ai des
puces il y a des puces partout autour de
ma serviette enfin je vous rassure quand
même ce sont des puces de mer rien à
voir avec celle qu'il y a sur le dos du
chien de ma grand-mère en effet rien à
voir d'ailleurs contrairement aux puces
du chien de la grand-mère des vannes les
puces de mer plus de sable ne sont pas
des insectes ce petit animal qui ne
dépasse pas 25 mm est incrusté comme le
homard ou la langoustine on trouve ses
puces sur de nombreuses plages d'Europe
elles hibernent entre octobre et mars ce
qui signifie quel point le bout de leur
petite antenne au beau jour justement au
moment où nous mettons les pieds sur les
plages avec leurs petites pattes les
puces de mer peuvent creuser jusqu'à 15
cm en profondeur pour trouver de la
fraîcheur ou tout simplement pour
s'abriter et lorsqu'elles sont à la
surface elles font parfois des sauts de
plus de 1 m rapporté à leur taille c'est
énorme c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
les appelle les puces de mer décidément
ces bestioles sont pleines de surprises
par contre pas touche à ma compote les
puces si vous envoyez autour de vous sur
votre serviette surtout ne les écrasez
pas les puces de mer jouent un rôle
important dans l'entretien de nos plages
elles font le ménage en aérant le sable
et en se nourrissant des déchets en
décomposition et restent dalles par
exemple c'est pour cette raison qu'on
met surnomme éboueur des mers et puis
elles sont aussi une source de
nourriture pour les goélands vous le
voyez ces petites puces sont précieuses
oh non ma puce elle est partie se cacher
sous ma serviette maintenant je vais
vous présenter quelques spécimens qui
vivent sous le sable suivez-moi
[Musique]
en creusant avec ces toutes petites
pattes que l'on appelle des soins le
verre arenicole se nourrit des sédiments
et des bactéries qui sont présents dans
le sable et se débarrassent de surplus
chaque vers mesure entre 15 et 30 cm de
long ce qui en fait un appât très prisé
par l'épaisseur beaucoup plus surprenant
c'est vert à renic Hall possède des
vertus thérapeutiques en Bretagne des
chercheurs qui travaillent au sein d'une
start-up ont découvert que leur sang a
un grand pouvoir oxygénant son
hémoglobine peut fixer 40 fois plus
d'oxygène que l'hémoglobine du sang
humain mieux encore il est compatible
avec tous nos groupes sanguins les mots
globines du ver arénécole peut donc
servir de substitut pour les
transfusions sanguines or vous le savez
on manque considérablement de sang le
hémoglobine est également précieuse en
cas de transplantation d'organes le sang
de ce verre permet d'oxygéner le greffon
ce qui laisse plus de temps pour le
conserver intact durant son transport
jusqu'à la personne à transplanter mes
amis tu crois qu'il y a un risque qu'on
se transforme en verre
il a peur de trinquer mais sévère ne
sont pas la seule richesse du sous-sol
de la plage vous êtes peut-être friands
des coques des palourdes ou des couteaux
qui se nichent dans le sable à chaque
marée basse d'ailleurs j'ai toujours
rêvé de dénicher un couteau comme
celui-ci moi-même est-ce que vous
connaissez la technique regardez la
parole qu'on a deux trous ça pourrait
être un couteau il suffit de mettre du
gros sel et normalement le couteau sort
normalement pas de chance Evan tu n'es
peut-être pas dans le bon trou ou alors
un autre pêcheur t'a devancé mais
pourquoi les couteaux sortent-ils de
leurs trous au contact du sel tout
simplement parce qu'on leur fait croire
que la mer est remontée de son instinct
le pousse alors à rejoindre la surface
pour se nourrir sauf que malheureusement
pour lui ce n'est pas de l'eau de mer
qu'il trouve mais la main du pêcheur qui
le capture pour en faire son repas et je
peux vous dire que les taux c'est très
très bon Sami je crois que j'en ai
trouvé un
je vous avais pas dit mais j'ai un
diplôme en effet spéciaux maintenant que
la mer est haute est condensé plus sur
les bestioles qui vivent sur et sous le
sable connaissez-vous Aurélie c'est
l'une des espèces de Méduse les plus
courantes en France même titre que la
pédagogie d'ailleurs si vous les croisez
faites bien attention elles ont tendance
à être un peu piquante il faut se méfier
des méduses ça pique ce qui ont vécu
cette douloureuse expérience s'en
souviennent en général toute leur vie la
méduse fait partie de la famille des
cnidaires comme les coraux schnil en
grec signifie piqué elle pique avec de
tout petits harpons qui recouvrent cette
tentacule quand une proie ou un danger
s'approche et touche les petits cils qui
tapissent les tentacules le harpon se
déploie à l'extérieur et va se planter
dans les tissus de la victime le venin
est alors injecté l'opération ne dure
que quelques millisecondes c'est l'un
des phénomènes les plus rapides dans la
nature
en fait si vous croisez une méduse
déchus sur la plage c'est sûrement à
cause des courants des vents des marais
qui l'ont entraîné et emporté vers les
côtes les méduses nage mal alors bien
souvent elles s'échouent sur le sable
elles vont mourir malheureusement en
séchant en plein soleil pendant les six
heures de marée basse même morte les
méduses piquent encore alors si vous
vous promenez au bord de l'eau faites
bien attention à leur filaments à ce
sujet vous voulez que je vous raconte ma
vie oui c'est super l'été dernier
c'était à Gruissan en Méditerranée et
quand je suis allé me baigner j'ai pas
vu de Méduse mais en fait il y avait
encore des morceaux de leur filament
dans l'eau et ça a suffi à me faire des
petites irritations sur le bras et oui
j'habite à raison je m'en souviens
encore que faut-il faire en cas de
piqûre de méduse première règle surtout
ne pas frotter en frottant on libère la
totalité du venin contenu dans le harpon
et on risque des brûlures beaucoup plus
sérieuses il faut d'abord rincer à l'eau
de mer j'ai bien dit l'eau de mer parce
que l'eau douce provoque l'effet inverse
elle provoque la libération du venin
ensuite il faut piéger les harpons qui
sont restés collés et pour cela il y a
un produit miracle qui va peut-être vous
surprendre et la mousse à raser alors je
sais il y en a pas dans notre sac de
plage mais en général il y en a dans
tous les postes de secours c'est un
buvard qui va piéger les harpons
ensuite à l'aide d'un carton rigide une
carte bancaire ou une carte d'identité
et bien on retire la mousse qui a
emprisonné les harpons et le venin on
rince une seconde fois à l'eau de mer
puis pour neutraliser le venin qui a été
libéré on aose la zone touchée avec un
produit un peu acide du vinaigre ou du
citron même chose il y en a dans les
postes de secours on rince à nouveau à
l'eau de mer puis on applique un
antiseptique je croyais qu'il fallait
faire pipi dessus moi surtout pas c'est
une légende urbaine qui s'est propagée
avec la série Friends
[Musique]
contient en fait de nombreuses bactéries
qu'il vaut mieux éviter de répandre sur
la plaie au risque de causer une
surinfection les algues ma grand-mère me
dit toujours que c'est bon pour la
circulation pas étonnant qu'elle passe
ta vie en thalasso d'ailleurs il y a
plein de petits animaux qui eux aussi
apprécié ces paquets d'algues que l'on
trouve au bord de la plage on appelle ça
la laisse de mer une petite salade
d'algues que j'ai mis peut-être prépare
en une j'arrive juste après la vidéo la
laisse de mer est composée de débris
déposés par la mer et qui s'accumule sur
la plage au fil des marées c'est des
briques peuvent être d'origine naturelle
comme les algues les coquillages le bois
des restes d'animaux ou bien
malheureusement d'origine humaine des
bouteilles en plastique des canettes de
soda ou des restes de filets de pêche la
laisse de mer c'est un véritable
garde-manger pour une ribambelle de
petits animaux notamment les mouches qui
pondent au fil des marais et laissent
leurs larves grandir dans les algues
pendant plusieurs semaines
là je cherche des cloportes habitués de
nos plages qui se nourrissent de
morceaux de bois ou parfois de petits
cadavres bon appétit ces algues séchées
sont un vrai festin pour d'autres
insectes mais aussi pour des araignées
des araignées de dunes qui viennent dans
la Lesse de mer pour chasser leurs
proies bon rassurez-vous elles sont
totalement inoffensives on y trouve
également de nombreux crabes qui
viennent se nourrir tiens à ce propos
comment font les crabes pour respirer
quand la mer est basse le crabe n'a pas
de poum comme les poissons il respire
dans l'eau grâce à des branches chez lui
elles sont situées dans des cavités il
en possède de elle lui permettent de
capter l'oxygène contenu dans l'eau et
d'évacuer le gaz carbonique contenu dans
son sang lorsqu'il est dans la mer ses
cavités se remplissaient l'eau circulent
en permanence autour des bronchies sauf
qu'à marée basse notre crabe n'a plus
d'eau pour respirer mais il a un truc il
ferme ses cavités qu'il a pris soin au
préalable de remplir d'eau ces réserves
vont lui permettre de continuer à
respirer bien sûr ça ne peut pas durer
éternellement car rien qu'un moment où
il a consommé tout l'oxygène dissout
dans ses réserves mais heureusement pour
lui la mère remonte toujours à temps et
notre crabe peut à nouveau respirer
tranquillement dans l'eau cette fois en
été certaines communes ramassent la
laisse de mer avec de gros engins de
chantier pour des raisons purement
esthétiques sauf qu'en faisant ça on
prive tout un écosystème de nourriture
alors la prochaine fois que vous verrez
ces grandes bandes d'algues sur le sable
ne soyez pas dégoûtés dites-vous plutôt
que c'est une sorte de buffet audio
can-eat pour toutes les petites
bestioles de la plage d'ailleurs j'ai
mis ça y est il est temps que je me
jette à l'eau
heureusement mon caméraman assure dans
ce qu'il faut non mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais mais on avait dit sur le bras pas
sur le visage la mousse à raser merci
Evan j'espère que la mousse à raser va
un peu apaiser tes douleurs si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à liker
et à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait et surtout indiquez en commentaire
les sujets que vous aimeriez que l'on
traite avec Evan bonne semaine à toutes
et à tous à la plage ou ailleurs et à
dimanche prochain
[Musique]
regarde regarde regarde regarde regarde
regarde